videogiochi di qualità allora ragazzi io
ho abbandonato è più visse per dare un
senso di nuova la mia vita e se
riuscissi a partire sarebbe un buon
inizio cosa che non riesco a fare porta
ma quanto può essere difficile cliccare
non c'era anche il mouse è la cosa più
ironica e che l'ho pagato tipo 15 euro
quindi fantastico il joystick funziona
perfetto ragazzi anche in italiano
quindi direi che siamo a cavallo
io il cavallo grazie ma qualcuno che mi
spiega come si gioca che non mario
calcio a mario ragazzi stiamo per
partire o finalmente cos'è sta roba
parti box
non so giocare io aiuto ho messo la lama
lì io non ho 12 a partire aiuto veloci
ma io non ho capito io devo battere loro
in velocità o dobbiamo arrivare alla
fine tutti insieme c'è gioco sa chi
arriva prima
melo sucate tutti ce l'ho fatta avete
visto tutti che è arrivato prima io
quindi gli altri si fottano giusto cioè
non ho capito ma non troppo facile
niente punti come niente punti tua madre
l'hack è male sono morto come acer a
cosa che sparava porca vacca morta
c'è però da borgo cavallo però sono
morto solo io so io sto stronzo qua ma
va a cagare ma io posso anche tirare i
calci come melo sucate
non è vero mai nella vita media o
chiamino è morto anche il camaleonte non
sono da solo nome non è possibile
sfavorito raperonzolo mandato a cagare
vabbè ma un casino come faccio violo ci
sono ci sono il nostro vivo o delle
frecce nell'anno però sono vivo e gli
altri sono morti quasi tutti tranne
quello bianco no porca vacca ci avrei
sperato un sacco
attenzione attenzione recupera il
camaleonte ragano mi piace mi sta
piacendo un sacco lo giuro ci mettiamo
noi i nostri stessi ostacoli e poi
dobbiamo farla noi la gara c'è una roba
è malato sto gioco ma posso essere morto
mai sull'ascensore un idiota raga ma
veramente ha vinto york rush 6 la
ultimate lo scoiattolo ai ragazzi la
fattoria questa coscienza io quindi
dovremo non fare troppo schifo
va bene vai
vi deve venire la cirrosi epatica al
fegato
i miei prossimi tre pasti da essere
umano saranno camaleonte furetto e pollo
come faccio a fare così schifo io mi
rifiuto di prenderlo raga allora termina
partita voglio il rischio del sì voglio
disconnettersi dal gioco bene non lo
scegliamo noi scegliamo l'elefante rosa
perché gli elefanti rosa sono carini e
non ci arriviamo mai raga lo sapete vero
va bene via voglio vederli morire tutti
prima di andare io uno è andato
cali anche tu per cortesia grazie molto
gentile ok ok o che peccato sono morti
tutti questi quasi stop a fermo non
farci un cazzo mi godo il momento era il
cavallo che faceva schifo non ero io
tutta colpa dei cavalli l'ho sempre
detto che i cavalli fanno sono persone
schifose lì è veramente brutta perché dà
più fastidio che altro la porta si apre
si cade giù
occhio che questa veramente brutta no mi
sono scocciato non è vero sono riuscito
a schiacciarli siamo morti tutti
potreste morire schiacciati tutti di
nuovo grazie non avrai la vittoria
lurido su chiamerò no non è vero
dovrò saltare sono stupido non ho
saltato devo saltare non ho saltato
porca vacca ha salvato secondo è ti
fotte sta roba che non devi saltare non
ci ho pensato troppo facile niente punta
se vinciamo tutti non dai punti meglio
perché ero arrivato secondo meglio così
ecco sono morto io a figurati porca di
mappe vag calai da ci mancava niente
schiacciati schiacciati godo la vita
morti tutti e nessuno ha vinto bene
quando vinco io si disconnettono tutti
perché a tutti quanti bruciar culo ti
distruggo proprio il cosa così dura
così almeno io se mi distruggo il suo
coso in teoria dovrei essere vantaggiato
io perché io so farla la strada che ho
fatto prima credono vai prego hai già
perso ha già perso perché gli hanno
tolto non se n'è accorto pensavi di
avere il tuo oggettino lì è allora i
nostri esca vincere noi mi sono
schiacciato il nostro vivo
no no non è vero vacca se io ho finito
getting over it
ok ho finito uno dei giochi più
difficile al mondo
non posso perdere come superato tua
madre zoppa nuova iena no raga io mi
rifiuto di rifiuto di crederlo ma come
faccio a perdere io dai rega ma che
guarda guarda riguarda ma veramente
dentista la famiglia tela riduco in
poltiglia fa anche rima
non è vero sono filosofico e adesso è
schiacciamo una buona volta è che dici
moriamo hai voglia di morire perché non
muori
perché non lo sto vedendo ancora morire
niente non muore lui non vuole gesù o no
no si ok si è fatto ce l'ho fatta ma
adesso schiatti però è adesso schiatti
ti voglio vedere morire voglio vederti
praga dove vincere un'altra volta
zitti zitti lo vince un'altra volta ho
vinto tutto ho tratto la tattica
no mi ha tirato un pugno come sua madre
morta di epatite c
porca vacca live dai dai minimi capitoli
vic ha vinto ha vinto
no mi ha solo recuperato bene se io
ammazzo lui con una mia trappola prendo
più punti capito che anche una questione
di ammazzare l'altro non è solo
questione di vincere un casino sto gioco
non è vero non è vero non è vero non è
vero
ok perfetto point cioè fatto ragazzi
allora deve arrivare lui cosa che forse
non riesce a fare adesso convinto non ce
l'ha fatta è morto è morto forse ho
vinto falso vinto lui è morto non lo so
non mi porta lo porterai a troppo forte
dai frate è tutto nelle tue mani se non
arrivi al traguardo vinto io prego che
bello quando stai già assaporando la
vittoria e non ce l'hai ancora grigio
ma che buono l'odore di vittoria mi
piace un sacco
se il altrimente elefante credo
effettivamente di aver trovato il nuovo
happy miss in tutto e per tutto ciò è
fantastico e molto meglio tra l'altro
perché è personalizzabile quindi non è
mai scontato e fantastico sto gioco ho
capito come si gioca cosa che non avevo
capito all'inizio tempio nella giungla
ragazzi non chiedetemi cosa cosa diavolo
sia però non lo facciamo
l'inizio è in realtà è un po una cagata
cioè nel senso dovrebbe essere
abbastanza semplice
non è vero perché sono morto bene porca
eva morta lercia niente quindi sono
morte ha vinto una persona sola a sea
morti tutti che culo meno male che ho
detto l'inizio è facilissimo se vinciamo
sempre tutti non ne avevo già morti
tutti effetto ok all e tocca a voi
ragazzi lo scoiattolo lì prima c'è
sempre
e infatti siamo arrivati noi due ok è
morto solo colori e va beh avrei sperato
morissero in più persone così prendevo
più distacco prof
non è vero non è vero la mia trappola
schifosa ma ucciso porcava se vince se
vincevo quest'anno fatto un miliardo di
punti perché aveva ammazzato tutti io e
la mia trappola remo superata invece non
l'ho superata per niente
porca vacca
no no no chi mi ha colpito non è vero
mai
cioè ha vinto veramente quel
rincoglionito lì no no non è vero che il
medico non puoi vincere tu non come
rifiuto di vedere quel deficiente
vincere mi rifiuto ve lo giuro
ci siamo morti tutti come come schifo
abbiamo fatto a morire tutti commerce
chamack ha vinto rincoglionito quadro no
porca di una bacca dai ragazzi ci hai
pensato ragazzi mi fa troppo incazzare
non posso sostituirla happy bis
no no no no no no sono vivo sono i voli
no porca vacca se non schiattati tutti
niente ragazzi quello continua a essere
inglobato dalle frecce
no non è vero non è vero a ok sono in
atto sarà grato se arrivato
sto parlando quindi ci sono arrivato e
ci arriva ma vabbè lasciamo perdere ma
va a cagare come morire tutta la stima
anche tuo figlio per 1 anno ha vinto
nessuno a un'ora e mezza in cui io dopo
un'ora di tentativi li avremmo fatti 40
e vince lui ma ho capito che sia
piaciuto ragazzi come mi piace fatemi
sapere quante altre bisogno di questa
roba che mi sembra carino se avesse
siete non ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
video da reja